>> Laura: LAST NIGHT, WE WERE
THE ONLY ONE TO BRING YOU THE
STORY OF HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF CONGOLESE IMMIGRANTS BEING
DROPPED OFF IN SAN ANTONIO AFTER
CROSSING THE BORDER.
FOR MANY OF THEM, THAT'S NOT THE
FINAL STOP.
DR. COLLEEN BRIDGER REVEALED
THIS TO A LOCAL CBS STATION.
"THE PLAN WAS 350 OF THEM WOULD
TRAVEL FROM SAN ANTONIO TO
PORTLAND MAINE.
WHEN WE REACHED OUT TO PORTLAND,
MAINE, THEY SAID DON'T SEND US
ANYMORE.
WE'RE ALREADY STRETCHED WAY
BEYOND OUR CAPACITY."
WHY WOULD PORTLAND BE BEYOND
THEIR CAPACITY?
I WANT TO GO BACK TO JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR WHEN JANET MILLS GAVE
HER INAUGURAL ADDRESS.
>> WE WELCOME THE VOICES OF
NEWCOMERS TO THE PUBLIC
CONVERSATION, THE YOUNG, THE
IMMIGRANTS, PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT
CULTURES, ALL ARE IMPORTANT
MEMBERS OF THE MAINE FAMILY.
FROM NOW ON, YES, A SIGN WILL
GREET ALL OF THOSE ARRIVING IN
OUR STATE AND IT WILL SAY SIMPLY
WELCOME HOME.
>> Laura: ISN'T THAT NICE?
IN PORTLAND ALONE, ASYLUM
SEEKERS THAT ARE PRIMARILY FROM
AFRICAN COUNTRIES MAKE UP 90% OF
THE PEOPLE LIVING IN A CITY RUN
FAMILY AND OVERFLOW SHELTERS.
BACK TO TODAY.
WHEN THE SAN ANTONIO MANAGER'S
REQUEST TO PORTLAND WAS TURNED
DOWN, THE RESPONSE WAS JARRING.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM TO
IDENTIFY OTHER CITIES THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES WHERE THEY CAN
GO AND BEGIN THEIR
ASYLUM-SEEKING PROCESS.
WHERE ARE THESE MIGRANTS GOING
TO BE DROPPED NEXT?
THAT'S ANYONE'S GUEST.
THE FACT THAT TWO CITIES IN TWO
STATES, THOUSANDS OF MILES APART
ARE BOTH AT CAPACITY?
SHOULD BE ALARMING FOR ALL
AMERICANS.
WE REACHED OUT TO OFFICIALS IN
PORTLAND, MAINE AND RECEIVED THE
FOLLOWING RESPONSE FROM A CITY
COUNSELOR.
PORTLAND IS PROUD TO BE A
WELCOMING CITY AND THOSE SEEKING
TO BECOME AN AMERICAN.
NO CITY OF 67,000 PEOPLE CAN
POSSIBLY MANAGE TO ENTIRE
NATION'S IMMIGRANT SITUATION ON
ITS OWN.
WOW!
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO